Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Also ich gebe mir auf jeden Fall Mühe, dass die Integrität und Vertraulichkeit meiner informationstechnischen Systeme gewährleistet ist.
Integer unvertraulich, so kennt ihr uns, Lokbuch Netzpolitik in seiner einhundertneunundsiebzigsten Inkarnation,
aus der Meterebene in eure Hörgänge gespürt. Ähm,
Ja und heute machen wir mal wieder das, was wir immer ein Spezial nennen. Stimmt's?
Ja, heute machen wir ein Spezial.
Spezial und wie sich das für so ein Spezial gehört hat man dann auch einen speziellen Gast, nämlich die.
Nein, nein, Spezialexpertin.
Genau. Äh der geneigte Hörer äh ahnt schon worum es geht.
Wir haben gerade gesagt, wir haben nur Hörerinnen.
Äh ja, sorry, jetzt ist alles alles durch. Die geneigte Hörerin ahnt schon, worum es geht.
Es geht um die Staatstrojanerin.
Heute machen wir das gedärische Feminum zur Staatsresion. Genau.
Der Konstanze niemals beigebracht.
Nein, nein, bestimmt nicht. Das scheitert auch so ein bisschen. Äh lassen wir den Sport auch wieder.
Passiert, es gab ein Urteil vom Bundesverfassungsgericht und äh ja äh bisher ein Dauergast, ne.
Wie viele Male warst du jetzt eigentlich schon da? Also ich weiß es tatsächlich.
Fremden auf.
Vorrats habe ich ge.
Wow, gibt's eine Schnittchen, wenn man da so? Nee.
Wie du, man darf da Kaffee mit reinbringen? Gestern Morgen. Äh, aber keine Muttermilch in Flughafen oder was.
Nur ins Bundesverfassungsgericht.
Das heißt, da sitzen dann alle so mit ihren Thermoskannen und Plastikbechern. Das ist schönes Bild. Jawoll. Ja.
Die Leute, die waren ja in der Anhörung auch da.
Hat auch gesehen, dass der Gerd Baum flatterig war. Noch abends in der Tagesschau bei der im Nachtmagazin war das so, aber wir haben das in den Linksessen. Das fand ich schon geil.
Aber.
Man kriegt so ein Rätsel, wie wie früher beim Orakel von Delfi, du fragst uns was und es antwortet in einem Rätsel.
Also ich bin wie zufrieden.
Deswegen fährst du auch immer wieder hin.
Genau, du warst also das als Sachverständige da mit einer.
Alleine, also ich meine, hat ja.
Geschrieben, kann man, glaube ich, auch sagen, ne? Äh Konstanze kurz, Frank Rieger, Dirk Engling, Thorsten Schröder haben diese Stellungnahme geschrieben, von der wir jetzt später noch reden wollen, aber wir haben uns ja überlegt, wir wollen vielleicht
Dieses Urteil mal in den geschichtlichen Kontext setzen, denn diese Geschichte,
BKA Gesetz oder in diesem Fall insbesondere Staatstrojaner beschäftigt ja äh die Bundesrepublik äh das Bundesverfassungsgericht und äh den Chaos-Computerclub ja schon seit einiger Zeit, seit acht Jahren,
Also noch länger, ne? Und es ging, die Geschichte geht los, zweitausendacht mit dem,
Ersten in der Hinsicht relevanten Urteil vom Bund des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, in dem äh wir ein äh neues Grundrecht gewonnen haben,
war da, was du da auch schon als Sachverständige oder nur als interessierte Beobachterin.
Aha.
Großer Fokus auf die Technik der Rücken stehen, noch an der Feuerwehr, da muss ich die ganzen Themen sehr spannend. Es war die.
Dass das niveautechnisch hoch war, kann ich mir bei Andreas Book als Sachverständigen auch nicht anders vorstellen. Aber dieses Gericht hat,
hast du mir glaube ich schon öfter so gesagt, das Gericht ist da sehr interessiert,
Solchen komplizierteren oder nicht alltäglich komplexen Ausführungen,
Äh durchaus mal auch zu folgen. Äh oder.
So, verstehen, da steht man nicht.
Der hat sehr, sehr strukturiert. Letztes Mal liegt da war durch das Lo.
Der hat jetzt erstmal starkes Foto.
Wo sind wir denn, ehrlich? Ich meine, das Bundesverfassung, du kannst ja nicht einfach melden, so irgendwie vom Jahrmarkt, obwohl da meldet.
Ist sie deutlich offen. Ich finde auch, dass es der Quartier,
Zwischenruf und die anderen sagen. Jetzt ist es auch nicht mehr so, dass vorher total klar, als wenn man spricht.
Ein oder anderen Salat auch schon mal erlebt. Beide Essensarten könnt ihr noch eins rein. Da hat jeder der diese Behandlung für dich so reinhau.
Wenn's der Wahrheitsfindung dient.
Vielleicht ähm bleiben wir trotzdem nochmal kurz bei der Geschichte, also zweitausendacht an äh zweitausendsieben Anhörung Andreas,
Urteil war zweitausendacht, glaube ich.
Und da wurde verhandelt ein nordrhein-westfälischer Staatstrojaner oder die.
Natürlich kommt die Bundesregierung, wenn ihr Testballon auf einmal bis nach Karlsruhe geflogen ist, ne?
Premiere prägen. Das ist der Teig kopieren, hat die.
Betrifft.
Denn zweitausendacht,
Wir haben das neue Grundrecht gewonnen, das Grundrecht auf Gewährleistung der Integrität und Vertraulichkeit informationstechnischer Systeme. Ich hab's aufgeschrieben, bin ich ganz ehrlich, ich hab's. Ich zitiere das immer falsch. Ähm,
Da gibt's auch ein Chaosradio zu, äh Chaosradio hundert ähm zweiunddreißig mit dem Computerverwanzung,
welche Meinung hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht denn damals vertreten zweitausendacht.
Leisten. Desinformationsrechtssystem, deren Vertraulichkeit und Qualität.
Man muss ja diese Gewährleistung leisten, das schaffe ich auch. Geht das.
Viel von den sogenannten Kernreichschutz die Rede über Unternehmensgeschäfte.
Also Dinge, die man.
Mobiltelefonen haben überhaupt jeder Computer hat, aber trotzdem war schon klar, dass technische Geräte auch eben höchstpersönlich auch im Bereich.
Ist der ist diese Debatte da erst äh entstanden. Ich erinnere mich immer an so, weiß ich nicht, Filme wie Casino, wo oder überhaupt dieses
also Casino, da gibt's irgendwie diese Szenen, wo die, wo die S ihre, ihre Frauen telefonieren lassen und dann die Abhörenden, Beamten, dann das Tonbandgerät ausschalten und.
Schatz. Da ist diese ganze Kunze zu sagen. Danke dir für heute. Teste sogar der absolute.
Und zwar in der Erhebung. Vorher dafür sorgen, dass diese.
Küche haben oder nicht, ob kommt, welche für einen R.
Immer Sex, aber da geht's natürlich auch um Gespräche. Psychologen oder eben seinen Partner oder so, also eben. Ärzte.
Wird hier in dieser Küche.
Lasst die Sendung nicht zu früh abgleiten.
Egal, was Menschen vorgeworfen wur.
Getragen. Weil die.
Aber technisch, wenn ich so ein bisschen Gerät.
War das die Geburt dieser Idee der äh Quellentelekom,
Überwachung oder.
Ein bisschen vorher gestanden.
Die sogenannte Quellentheke, also.
Lassen.
Und.
Und ähm nochmal kurz also zweitausendacht wurde entschieden, beides geht oder.
Das ist ja der, also der eigentlich der normale Lauf, so.
Dirk, na ja, den kannst du ja nicht verhindern, ne? Wenn dir, wenn dein äh du du machst du machst ein Gesetz
Das Gesetz landet vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, das Bundesverfassungsgericht kommt seiner Aufgabe nach, äh dieses äh Gesetz auf Verfassungskonformität zu prüfen, ähm kommt zu dem Ergebnis dieses Gesetz ist
nicht verfassungsgemäß und begründet das ja und eine Begründung, warum etwas nicht verfassungsgemäß ist, ist ja gleichzeitig eine eine Anleitung,
die man beim zweiten Anlauf nicht überschreiten darf. Ähm.
Nicht geschafft haben.
Genau, aber das sehen wir ja bei den.
Also.
Da kommen wir ja, kommen wir ja gleich nochmal zu. Also ähm.
Ich sage nicht, dass ich den gut finde, aber es ist nicht ist es nicht das, was wir auch bei der,
Datenspeicherung in ähnlicher Form sehen ähm und ich sage mal, das ist der Weg, den man,
ob das jetzt normal oder unnormal ist, äh aber es ist das, was in der Regel,
ja es wird es passiert nicht, dass ein Gesetz,
begründet,
vom Bundesverfassungsgericht zurückgewiesen wird und die Urheber oder Proponenten des Gesetzes sagen, ach Mist ja okay, äh wir wir sind äh verfassungswidrige Leute, wir müssen mal unsere Hausaufgaben machen, sondern die sagen, okay, unsere Hausaufgabe lautet,
Gesetz so schreiben, dass die uns nicht mehr reinfunken, ja? Wir haben.
Es gibt ja also es gibt ja auch immer wieder von den von den Hardcore Leuten der CDU dann die Forderung, dass man irgendwie was gegen diese gegen dieses Bundesverfassungsgericht unternehmen muss, ne? Das ist ja auch irgendwie eine Forderung, die immer mal wieder äh gestellt wird. Ich glaube, äh.
Liebes Grüße aus Warschau, sage ich nur.
Und aus Ungarn. Ja, also es ist äh ist so ist so so ein so ein perfider Weg, so ist so gewisser, also ich weiß nicht, ob man das so als Faulheit,
einstufen soll, so nach dem Motto, daher egal, wir machen's jetzt mal nicht so viel Gedanken darüber, wir schreiben einfach mal alles rein, was wir gerne hätten und dann gucken wir mal, was davon durchkommt so,
ja oder ob das eben auch so kalkül ist so, ja, wir wollen einfach hier die maximale Verschärfung haben
und äh dann lassen wir da halt die äh Jungs in Karlsruhe da mal was subtrahieren und fertig. So.
Ja und alles, alles, was auch nur gerade soeben noch reinpasst, ist sozusagen auch sofort das, was man jetzt auch für angemessen hält. Und das ist natürlich auch schon ein bisschen perfide.
Nicht schön. Müsse eigentlich müsste eigentlich Punktabzug kriegen
Na ja, stell mal vor, so jeder Minister hätte sozusagen nur so fünf Verfassungspunkte, so für seine Legislatur und ähm,
ne, wenn man halt so äh so einen so einen Reinfall erleidet, dann kriegt man halt schon mal einen abgezogen und irgendwann hat man halt einfach keine mehr. Also ähm dann darf man irgendwie,
nicht mehr mitspielen oder so.
Das äh Verfassungssünder äh Register in Bielef.
Ja genau, so ein so ein Flensburg für Verfassungssünder.
Ja, mal gucken.
Zwischendurch müssen die jetzt im Hotel sehr zu sagen. Zweitausendneunzehn Karte trinken.
Aber so eine MPU könnte man dann vielleicht doch schon mal anordnen, oder?
Okay, also aber was, wie war die Stimmung nach dem Urteil zweitausendacht, da war sie ja wahrscheinlich eigentlich ganz gut, die Stimmung, ich meine, neues Grundrecht äh.
Selbstbestimmung.
Was genau hat so eine hohe Wirkung international? Ah okay.
Müssen wir vielleicht kurz erklären, Grundrecht auf,
formationelle Selbstbestimmung, welches Jahrzehnt neunzehnhundert.
Also seit neunzehnhundertfünfundachtzig. Also eigentlich vierundachtzig oder sozusagen genau in der an der Grenze zu mir, was? Äh.
Mit fundamental Garita und da haben sich halt auch viele andere Länder. Relativ weit vorne, sondern das sieht natürlich auch hier aus dem ganzen Aufeinander. Natürlich sind oft deutsche Rüstung.
Denn sie haben mehr gedacht als nur alle was zu dem Trojan haben. Genauso.
Man könnte ja sagen, also nicht für Trier, durch alles waren, auch wenn sie Geld nach.
Muss leider sagen, das sind ein groß.
Akademischen Bereich gibt, die sich dann interviewen wollen.
Passiert ist mit dem Urteil, dass man zweitausendneun mit einem BKA-Gesetz kam. Also genau das, der zweitausendacht eigentlich ein Urteil über Landesgesetzgebung und zweitausendneun wird diese
Urteilsbegründung herangezogen, um,
vielleicht auch nicht herangezogen, wie wir in dem noch weiter im weiteren Verlauf sehen, ähm um ein BKA-Gesetz zu setzen.
Und in diesem Gesetz wurden,
die in diesem Verfahren behandelten,
Themen eben auf Bundesebene ausgerollt als äh Rechte, die das Bundeskriminalamt erlangt.
Warum sind die? Warum sind die beiden so getrennt? Äh oder wie sind die ähm,
in der Verwaltung getrennt. Es gibt was, also wenn ich das Recht erinnere,
eben für die Online-Durchsuchung eine sehr viel höhere rechtliche Hürde als für die Quellen TKÜ.
Genau.
Und ist das äh.
Wahrscheinlich deckt sich das mit den mit den Verwaltungsrechtlichen Hürden, die man bei einer Hausdurchsuchung oder einem Telefonabhören hat, oder?
Ähm für die Onlineshop in der in dem Bereich es ist sehr, sehr wohl. Man muss.
Zweiter Verstoß. Ja.
Höchstpersönlich entwickeln, transkibieren da. Zweimal gegen Menschen. Ähm äh die Hirn sind also.
Gibt's halt bloß sehr, sehr wenig,
da brauchen wir sozusagen den selben Ansätzen. So kommt auch die Trennung zustande. Es hat auch Praktikabel sein.
Die Praktikabilität der Men.
Also die Trennung kommt aber natürlich auch.
Dem Markt der existiert.
Theater.
Ist das so? Ich,
ist ein Trojaner bauen müsste, wäre diese Skype Sache irgendwie mehr Arbeit,
ein, der einfach mir nur vollkommene Rechte auf dem Rechner gibt.
Einfach richtig äh und technisch besser einsetzen. Ähm, die Funktion zu beschränkungen, wenn man die sozusagen.
Erhin oder ich möchte, wie man so erzählt.
Zweitausendneun tritt dieses Gesetz in Kraft. Das ist äh eine Zeit, zu der diese ganze Überwachungsgeschichte wirklich viele Menschen ähm sehr stark beschäftigt hat.
Intensiv über diesen Alltag gefallen. Der sogenan.
Wir sind soziale Wissenschaften.
Dem äh vorgeworfen wurde, äh Mitglied einer terroristischen Überkopfbühne. Der russischen Verein.
Das auf Basis einer Tech-Cloud sozusagen. Ja.
Die gesamte technische.
Andre Heum hatte zum Thema der Jetrification von Städten
und oder Stadtteilen,
Sehr viel geforscht, forscht da immer noch zu betreibt, dass äh Gentry Gentrification Blog,
ich, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, ging's da, wie hießen die autonome Gruppe oder wie hieß die
militante Gruppe und die hatten in ihren.
Ja, ja, genau, MG.
Die hatten in ihren Texten äh Wörter benutz,
ähm die Terrorismusfahnder
nicht kannten und dann haben sie diese Wörter gegoogelt und sind auf die Texte von Andre Holm gekommen und haben gesagt,
ihn und seine Lebenspartnerin und Kinder und was vollständig.
In der Ferne.
Mhm. Der äh hatte,
Dieser Fall eigentlich noch äh rechtliche Konsequenzen nicht so wirklich, oder? Die einzige rechtliche Konsequenz war, dass man ähm ja.
U-Haft.
Äh also da aber rechtswidrig.
Oder auch irgendwann richtig eingestellt. Mehrere Jahre. Ähm ich weiß.
Beschuldigten würde man doch versuchen.
Wirtschaft einsetzen.
Ja. Ich sehe auch gerade Piratenpartei, hatte damals erste, die haben irgendwie,
Bei der zweitausendneuner Bundestagswahl zwei Prozent geholt und hatten sich damit,
von dieser.
Europa. Oh je, dann habe ich hier gerade kurz Bundestagswahl zweitausendneun steht hier.
Ja? Richtige Thema.
Genau, also es war,
Piratenpartei, wir haben die sind durchgedreht und haben irgendwie Soziologen eingesperrt, äh die ja, Andre Holm ist,
kann man einfach sagen, auf diesem, auf diesem Forschungsgebiet gibt's einfach glaube ich keinen, der so viel
Renomee hat wie er, dass er.
Ist eigentlich ganz schön, dass.
Sieg. Ähm aber also er hatte auf jeden Fall ich war zu der Zeit auch an dem äh an dem Institut und habe da ein paar Seminare besucht
und dann hing da irgendwie am Institut für Sozialwissenschaften der Humboldt Universität zu Berlin an die Musik lassen. Wir wollen hier wieder unser Seminar weitermachen und so. Ähm, also es kochte,
kochte hoch in der Zeit knallen die dann irgendwie so ein Gesetz rein und sagen jo äh Edgebatch,
Und dann passierte erstmal lange Zeit nicht wirklich was, ne, weil man nicht wusste, wie weit ist das BKA mit dem,
umsetzen.
Mhm. Wie kommt es, dass da sechs Jahre lang nichts geschehen ist.
Man kann nicht sagen, dass da nichts geschehen ist. Also äh so viel bekanntes über,
riesengroßes Gutachten geben.
Der Chaos-Computerclub hat dann in diese Zeit genutzt, ähm mal so einen Staatstrojaner,
äh zu analysieren,
Es war der äh Trojaner äh des Herstellers äh Digitas, der in Bayern zum Einsatz kam oder.
Ja, stellte sich die, das ist hin, hinlänglich bekannt, ich versuch das nur mal so zusammenzufassen, es gab diese Analyse, es gab eine sehr äh ausführliche Berichterstattung ähm in der Faz,
damals angetrieben von.
Gott hab ihn selig, der ähm dieses Thema äh wusste ähm äh zu,
setzen und jetzt
in den medialen Kontext zu setzen, der äh durch diesen Abdruck äh des des Quellcodes ähm beziehungsweise des des des des des Binarys oder war das das Disast als der Beliefercode, oder? Also des desasemblierten Codes ähm
ja irgendwie eine das war einfach eine,
Der hat das geschafft, dieses Thema zu setzen. Das war und der Chaoscomputerclub natürlich auch mit seiner Arbeit, aber das hat medial äh gezündet wie äh nichts Gutes.
Das war nämlich der wichtige, ob das jetzt halt, also ich meine, die die handwerkliche Qualität der polizeilichen Ermittlungswerkzeuge ist äh grundsätzlich kein ähm,
kein, kein, keine nichts, dass der Chaos-Computerclub sich
so ein interessanter Nebenaspekt, dass man über die Qualität auch lachen konnte, ne?
Genau. Probleme, die sich aus handwerklichen Fehlern ergeben, die rechtlich.
Genau, aber die der Kern der äh der Kern dieser Veröffentlichung war ja, dass dieser Trojaner Funktion hatte, die laut zweitausendachter Urteil und auch laut zweitausendneuner Gesetz äh einfach nicht.
Die waren einfach rechtswidrig. So, ne? Und wie gesagt, Qualität ist, ist eine Randnotiz vor dem Hintergrund, dass dass da ein ah ja.
Genau, das hatte.
Das war, das war durchaus peinlich, der Rechtsru.
Genau das, denke ich, ist eben der der wichtige Punkt, der auch dazu geführt hat, dass dieses ähm dieses Tool nicht mehr genutzt wurde, nicht mehr genutzt werden durfte. Sofort.
War das als äh hat's auch keiner mehr die Blöße gegeben? Es ging halt auch nicht mehr, ja.
Genau. Spring mir halt ein. Wie heißt das denn bei Windows?
Nee, ist egal. Also jetzt geschrieben und sie haben's ja wieder.
Ähm,
Genau, dann stand dann äh gegen das Theater los. Äh
kein Trojaner mehr. Wir müssen jetzt irgendwie gucken, wo wir einen herkriegen
Es gab relativ ausführliche ähm,
Dann auch immer wieder durch Leaks und Artikel dokumentierte Bemühungen unterschiedlicher äh staatlicher Behörden äh sich bei den üblichen Verdächtigen, ähm die ja äh in,
hauptsächlich in weiß ich im nahen Osten ein guten Ruf haben dort Trojaner, ein Diktatoren zu verkaufen, sich bei denen mal zu erkundigen. Wir sehen in den
liegst über von Gama von vor ein, zwei Jahren,
vom wir sehen die auch dokumentiert die Gespräche die Verträge, es gab dann irgendwie.
Genau, bei Hacking Team gab's in den E-Mails, die äh die Kontakte zu Verkaufsgesprächen.
Ich habe es ja gemacht. In der anderen. Ja. Ich erinnere mich noch, dass wir da abends.
Es gab aber eine PM von ihrem Mitarbeiter.
Unsere super Datenschützerin.
Ich habe eine PM von.
Also immerhin.
Also Frau Vossof äh begrüßt aber das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgericht,
Als
Ich sage nur, also ich habe nur gerade mal geguckt, ob sie sich überhaupt äh geäußert hat, wenn sie schon nicht äh vor Ort war und es gibt hier äh es gibt dann hier auf dieser Webseite die äh laut Titel Internetauftritt der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten heißt,
Ja, gibt's immerhin eine Pressemitteilung. Ja. Meilenstein für den Datenschutz.
Uiui. So, also Staatsreaner Heck haben wir auch. Ähm
Danach dokumentiert sehr sehr ausführliche Bemühungen und wenn ich mich nicht täusche, folgte dann äh
zweitausendfünfzehn jetzt als nächster signifikanter Meilenstein eben die Anhörung zu der Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen das BKA-Gesetz, die angestrengt worden war von
Unserem ehemaligen Innenminister.
Ah okay, wer die Beschwerdeführer sind?
Mhm. Also die haben so ein bisschen unterschiedliche Aspekte zu bestellen, aber greift vor allen Dingen, also sehr, sehr viele verschiedene.
Ich finde das ja so spannend, äh wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ähm war doch der Gerhard Baum als ähm Minister,
in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland durchaus auch mit,
Ähm aber um mir jetzt so diese Personalie einzuordnen, weil ich das schon sehr spannend finde als Innenminister,
wohl wirklich ein Wind äh sehte, der ähm,
Also ne, in der gesamtdeutschen Politik, äh wo kaum noch jemand Spaß verstanden hat, auch er nicht, aber ähm das, dass das jemand ist, der noch wirklich äh Jahrzehnte später äh sich für Verfassung,
und Freiheitsrechte als Anwalt äh engagiert. Aber es ist glaube ich auch ganz klar, dass der da jetzt nicht nur als,
Verteidiger oder Anwalt war, sondern der der liebt auch das, was er seine.
Und für sehr, sehr viele Orte. Also ich glaube, der Gerhard Baum bisschen verstehen, weil der sollte zwei Bücher, also es gibt eins, das heißt, meine Boute ist dunkel.
Neue Buch, das heißt der Baum und der Rill.
Ja
Auch ein sehr heiß wirklich die Anwälte so.
Maler.
Versteht man glaube ich, wie die warum.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das erzählen kann.
Die ähm wir hatten da ja nicht.
Ist er schon beim nächsten Thema sozusagen?
Und die wurde am Dienstag verabschiedet, oder? Donnerstag. War das und Donnerstag, aber na ja, das kann jeden. Wochenende. Ja, äh also mit Unter war ja jetzt. Ja.
Also der war jetzt, ne? Ja. Hatten wir noch gar nicht befasst, oder? Ja.
Lokwohnnetzpolitik wird bericht.
Ist ein bisschen aus der Spur gerade, aber wir holen das nach. Ja, ja, ist äh die Taktrate ist schon teilweise recht hoch.
Äh gibt's da schon wieder Neues? Hm, läuft's?
Aufhören, wir müssen das hier alles abarbeiten. Ich werde da mal irgendwie den hinschreiben. Das geht ja wohl so nicht.
Genau, liebe Bundesregierung, macht mal ein bisschen langsamer, wir kommen nicht mehr hinterher. Was sollen wir denn das machen? Genau.
Anhörung ähm zweitausendfünfzehn, du kriegst obwohl ja quasi die
Beschwerde sechs Jahre anhängig ist, hast, weiß ich, kann man vielleicht aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern relativ kurzfristig die die Bitte bekommen dort als Sachverständige aufzutreten, ich glaub das war weniger als 'n Monat.
Das war eben, was muss man dir vor fünfhundert,
sechshundertsiebenhundert, du zeigst jetzt, er geht in meinem Podcast schwierig.
Haben sie das denn alles gelesen, Frau Doktor Kurz?
Leseratte.
Zur der Anhörung habt ihr habt ihr damals damals TM zweitausendfünfzehn auch,
Ist noch nicht äh auch ein Netzwerk Podcast gemacht, den es in den Shownotes gibt, da waren glaube ich du und äh Ulf äh Burmeier in, bei, bei Netz, bei Mark,
wir hoffen und ähm vielleicht fast ja trotzdem nochmal kurz zusammen, wie es denn da so war für dich.
Sehr, sehr lange fehlen. Über fünf Stunden.
Hat im Prinzip genauso.
Aber viel mehr.
Und dann aber auch so ganz grundsätzliche Fragen.
Wurde aus meiner Sicht immer nicht erst probieren, aber ich hatte Glück. So, dass sie eigentlich äh.
Beschrieben haben. Auch äh andere Sachverständiger. Ich war einfach ein bisschen glücklich, dass sie.
Schon ärgerlich, wenn man sich dann davon so etwas nach nach irgendwie so vielen Jahren der Vorbereitung ähm die Sachverständigen so zeitlich unter Druck setzt und dann auch noch irgendwie nur an einem Tag da.
Auch der Bericht.
Berichteten im bayrischen Landesvorstand. Ich lese nicht. Schreib bitte nicht, ob du mich selbst mal zu der sagen kann.
Das heißt, sie fragen dann unter Umständen auch, die einfach ihre Verständnisfragen zu dem gelesenen, was sie ohnehin schon,
war.
Stimmt, du hattest, die war ja jetzt irgendwie einen Tag vorher fertig oder am Tag selber oder? Ja.
War die schon bei dieser Anhörung? Ich ja und weil ich das nächste, was nämlich jetzt zur Zeit in der Zeitmarke war, war ja im Februar, glaube ich, diesen Jahres, als dann äh Herr Münch, Johannes, wir sind fertig. So
und ähm die haben,
Wie kann man sich das erklären, dass sie noch Vorurteilsverkündungen so selbstsicher sagen? Wir sind fertig. Also ist ja auch vielleicht von der äh,
Selbst wenn also nachher stellte sich ja jetzt heraus, dass der Leistungsumfang dieses,
Quellen TK Ü Troianas, den sie da haben, dann doch sehr ähm,
geschränkt ist, was ja wohl durchaus auch richtig sein kann, aber äh wir haben viele äh Quengeleien dann gelesen von,
Polizeivertretern, die sagten, da kann man nichts mit anfangen, der kann nur bei Windows Rechnern Skype abhören, ja.
Teil das.
Das iPhone kam zweitausendzehn, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, oder.
Sieben.
Zweitausendsieben A, okay, als Rene dann äh also dann kam mein iPhone zweitausendzehn.
Das kann sein.
Ja, ja. Und auch sozusagen nochmal diese, das ist ja, das ist hier.
Auf jeden Fall, das hat wirklich auch mal wirklich mal was verändert. Ich meine, diese,
Diskussion wird ja in den Kreisen schon lange geführt, aber ich hab auch so den Eindruck, dass es,
vor allem es hat auch dazu geführt, dass auch in den Kreisen einige ähm,
wie soll ich sagen, Zweifler vielleicht oder etwas zurückhaltender äh argumentierender, die sich auch immer so ein bisschen mit so einem optimistischen, kann ja so schlimm wird's nicht sein. Ding, dass die diese Position äh auch äh wirk
spült haben und das ist dadurch auch einfach mehr Verbreitung gefunden haben.
Würde ich mich sogar würde ich mich sogar fast selber dazu zählen.
Niemand anders. Jetzt denken alle, ich hätte hier irgendwas fürchterliches gemacht.
Stück weit auf jeden Fall.
Zweitausend,
Aber also was man glaube ich sagen kann als dieses BKA-Gesetz zweitausendneun formuliert wurde ist man wenn man vielleicht an so ein Smartphone gedacht hat haben sie gesagt OK die E-Mails die wir auf dem Computer dann mit unserem Staatstrojaner holen äh die,
Können auch auf so einem Telefon abgeholt werden, aber da das hat wahrscheinlich noch keiner sich gedacht, dass es inzwischen einfach für die Menschen wahrscheinlich mehr Daten auf ihren Telefonen gibt,
als auf auf ihrem Computer, die für Strafverfolgungsbehörden relevant sind oder äh eh von Interesse sind.
Mhm.
Der Gesetzgeber.
Mhm. Im Internet of Things, Cloud, ganze Programm.
Automobildebatte gehör.
Also das Urteil ist verwandt, weil es ist weitsichtig und es kam vor allem auch zu eine
sehr interessanten Zeitpunkt, weil wenn man sich auch mal anschaut, wie man das Smartphone heißt ja jetzt nicht nur
dass da die Daten etwas geballter vorliegen, sondern es ist ja auch eine ganz andere Qualität von Privatsphäre, die sich dort eigentlich abzeichnet.
Genau, darauf wollte ich hinaus, ne? Also da ist einfach äh auf einmal Daten
nicht auch nur hingekommen sind, also nicht nur Bewegungsdaten, sondern mittlerweile kann das Ding ja,
alles erfassen. Bis hin eben auch zu Gesundheitsdaten et cetera, ne?
Ja, für viele Leute ist das das Leben. Absolut.
Zusehen, also die Zeit ist halt auch wenn wir auch damals schon irgendwie in Digital.
Oder nicht. Kommen wir zum Thema. Und nun zu etwas völlig anderem. Nein,
Jetzt wurde gestern geurteilt,
Medien, Medienecho ist dann irgendwie so äh Bundesverfassungsgericht stärkt äh Grundrechte oder äh.
Da drin sind nämlich auch.
Ja, na ja gut.
Wie die sind verboten, weil.
So ah okay, sorry, ich dachte jetzt in dem Urteil werden jetzt irgendwie Telefon verboten, das wäre echt Scheiße.
Das haben die nicht berichtet. Sor.
Ja, dann war's das mit der Liebe fürs Verfassungsgericht. Sagt mir mal, was der Tee noch mal, was hat jeder mitgekriegt sozusagen.
Also ähm ich denke, die.
Ich habe das nicht so live äh mitgetickert jetzt.
Ich kann jetzt mal so ein bisschen Überwachungskritisches Urteil, äh den hast du selber hast du gem.
Äh
BKA-Gesetz teilweise verfassungswidrig, Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgericht, was sich beim BKA-Gesetz ändern muss,
haben wir wieder dieses normal, ne? Da wird schon direkt selbst die Tagesschau berichtet schon völlig ganz klar, so wir haben hier, wir wissen jetzt, was bei was geändert werden muss. Äh Demazier, ähm der Bundesinnenminister ähm sprach eben von Bedenken, die er nicht teilt,
das ist gut, dafür sprach ähm,
Jetzt sprach Gerd Baum dann äh von äh Bedenken, die aber dann für ihn mit,
eilt und ähm,
Klatsche für die Koalition Teil Erfolg für Bürgerrechte wurde bei heiße Online getitelt,
dann melden sich natürlich die Vertreter der Polizeigewerkschaften ich glaub in dem Fall was Andre Schulz der sagt wir brauchen Gesetze die praktikabel sind aber was wirklich so ein bisschen fehlte war,
eine also ich glaube das Thema wurde öffentlich jetzt nicht,
aufbereitet, dass man das, sage ich mal so, beim Überfliegen,
eingängig versteht, was eben wahrscheinlich auch an dem an diesem Ausmaß äh dieses Gesetzes und auch,
ist das Urteil, was du hier liegen hast. So, das sind, ist das beidseitig bedruckt.
Waren, ich glaube, das waren ohne Anhänger hundertvierzig Seiten, ohne Anlagen.
Also ein Zentimeter dicker Dinner vier Stapel.
Genau, die Sonne wohnten hängen da auch noch dran und dann sind's. Ja, das müssen jetzt so zweihundert sein.
Was sind Sondervoten? Äh die Entscheidung ist wirklich vergangen. Mhm.
Ja, hast du das schon angeschaut und mal geguckt, in welche Richtung die gehen?
Mhm.
Ist das eine ästhetisches Argument oder haben ähm wie.
Das heißt, sie sind die sind eher äh also ihre Argumentation ist eher, dass das Urteil nicht so stark einschränken sollte. Okay, das das na, ist halt, weil.
Also tendenziell schließen sie sich sozusagen der Mehrheit nicht so,
und hätten da eher noch ein Auge zugedrückt. Hm.
Deshalb ist es.
Nehmen sie ihr ernst, so wie er insgesamt erklärt, ja, wenn dann ernst am Ende.
Und wie war's? Ja,
Okay. Okay.
Dein Problem. Okay,
Das ist ja immer ein schöner Lackmusstest, ne? Man fragt erstmal, ja und Kosten übernommen, so, okay, dann.
Bevor ich jetzt äh zur Urteilsverkündung mein Zug buche und das jetzt hier nicht unnötig.
Ach, wir haben gewonnen hat, dann fliege ich doch besser. Nein, erzähl. Ja. Klar.
Das sind ja dann ähm das können ja dann doch schon durchaus mal äh sinken
kannte Beträge sein, die man jetzt also bis jetzt nicht, dass man sagt, dass,
ist jetzt nur Porto, ne? Wobei allein das Papier, ich meine, warte, ich guck dir mal die das wo das ist jetzt auch kein besonders,
Nein, ich meine, wie viel Papier so eine Anwalt äh produzieren muss in in diesem.
Gute Beschwerde.
Während eben so beschwerdeverfahren läuft, auch aktuelle DV. Und dann ist schon dieser beiden Tage.
Und die Beschwerdeführer haben eine Kostenerstattung bekommen.
Und wir schauen uns jetzt mal, weil das das Thema ist, was uns hier unter dem,
Zeichen der Netzpolitik am meisten interessiert, wenn natürlich weiter auf diese Staatströnergeschichte, ne? Das heißt die den.
Zwei Aspekte interessiert.
Und es im Namen des Volkes ergingen folgendes Urteil? Na ja, das man kann das leider, die Leitsätze sind halt verdammt kompliziert. Im Wesentlichen. Ich weiß.
Ja.
Das heißt, sie müssen in dem Gesetz schon definieren, wenn,
Online-Durchsuchung zum Einsatz kommt, müssen folgende Maßnahmen stattfinden, um den Kernbereich,
schützen, was weiß ich, Vermessung äh die so.
Verhältnismäßig heißt es soll im Paragraphen auch definiert sein, ähm im Rahmen welcher Anschuldigung oder welche welches Verdachts einer Straftat dieses Ermittlungsinstruments zum Einsatz kommt. Oder ähm.
Also.
Moment, die die Begriffe müssen wir glaube ich kurz erklären. Also äh notwendig und erforderlich, da hatte der Andre mir schon mal irgendwann Feedback gegeben äh zu einer Sendung, dass diese Begriffe im juristischen äh sehr,
Also wenn etwas muss erforderlich sein, heißt, es geht wirklich nicht ohne.
Genau. Das genau, erforderlich ist das mildeste Mittel ohne dass es nicht geht.
Teilweise eben mit diesem Kernfreistoff.
Wie.
Dann hast du diese Frage erzählt.
Wer darf nicht weiter nutzen.
Neuerhebung ist eine interessante Begriff Design. Soll ich sie orientieren sich daran?
Also das haben wir jetzt neue Begriffe abgeholt.
Also die, das heißt, die weiß nicht Verdächtigen dich äh des Mordes. Äh troanisieren deinen Computer und werden darauf werden da in im Laufe dessen darauf aufmerksam, dass du äh ich fallsharing machst.
Eine andere, also.
Dann ist die Frage, dürfen sie diese, die dadurch äh äh ermittelten Beweismittel in dem in dem anderen Ermittlungsverfahren nutzen oder dürfen sie aufgrund derer ein Ermittlungsverfahren eröffnen? Und dürfen sie oder nicht?
Ey.
Dieser Begriff ungefähr aussagen. Haben sie auch nicht das Stück hier drin, ne? Muss auch re,
wussten wir bestimmt wieder sagen die Pferde wird nicht korrekt, ich versuche deine Maschine. Das sagen die immer.
Sagen die immer und dann können sie es nicht besser. Also.
Die Frage ist.
Trägt aber auch man da so holt sich ganz besonders drüber gefreut, dass sie.
Geht's aber auch um.
Darf ich noch ganz kurz anfragen, du hattest gerade gesagt, die Speicherfristen für die durch Trojaner erlangten Daten waren zu kurz.
Okay.
Aufheben, dass man nachvollziehen kann. Man.
Okay. Die Daten, die sie erlangen,
die werden so lange aufbewahrt, wie Beweismittel aufbewahrt werden müssen, oder?
Für unterschiedliche Bandkarten auch neue Regeln entworfen.
Man bekommt eine Benachrichtigung.
Macht bitte immer alle schön eure Backups. Und wenn ihr mal Post kriegt.
Hm?
Solange passiert mit dem brauchen wir die sowieso nicht mehr.
Nachrichten dann am Ende in den seltensten Fällen, ja. Aber wenn man Pack-up.
Mhm. Und die Tatsache, dass es nicht Gewichtsverfahren gibt. Heißt.
Mhm.
Das gilt für Online-Durchsuchung und Quellen TKÜ gleichermaßen, was du bisher. Mhm. Ja. Ja.
Das ist das ist wahrscheinlich die größte Höhe.
Interesse daran ist, dass sie die Transparenten machen, die sie klare Leiden.
Ja, das ist auch ein.
Genau. Und insofern kann.
Gutes, guter Indikator.
Rechtsweg.
Dass sie ihnen, dass sie, wenn sie das Ding schon als Beweismittel dann irgendwann vielleicht mal tatsächlich vor Gericht,
dass ihnen das dann nicht noch abgesichert wird, ne?
Na ja, dann ist halt Wetter uns natürlich besonders interessiert halt. Wir haben diese natürlich eine Frage. Ähm ja.
Und leider ist es tatsächlich so, dass sie.
Das war genau der juristische Hakenschlag, den den eigentlich diese Quellen TKÜ,
ausgemacht hat, ne? Ähm.
Infiltration, das Rechner ist der entscheidende Sie, die einfach annehmen, sie sagen, es sind unser Problem, die technisch windig. Wir sagen.
Also ich meine, ich würde ja auch passen auf den Tag. Mhm. Aber sie nehmen vor allen Dingen an, dass man das technisch könnte. Man muss sich heute anpacken, dass äh.
Castingscreenshots von der Handbewegung und die blühende Mannschaft. Ja. Und da läuft mein.
Ich ich weiß nicht, was bei dir so läuft.
Sehr stark.
Ich bin nicht.
Dann ist das ihr Problem. Ja.
Das heißt, sie, also ein ein generelles Urteil darüber,
dass man jetzt das Grund das Grundrecht auf Wahrung, äh Gewährleistung der Intivität auch so verstehen kann, dass der Staat eben einfach zu sagen hat, wenn wir irgendwo von irgendeiner Sicherheitslücke wissen, dann ist es unsere.
Ist es das Grundrecht unserer Bürger, dass wir sie darüber in Kenntnis setzen und für ein,
zumindestens für ein Bekanntwerden, wenn nicht sogar aufschließen der Sicherheitslücke,
Sorge tragen. Diese.
Ja
Aber diese Sachen sind.
Da haben sie gar nichts zu gesagt. Das hätte ich ja mal schön gefunden. Wir wissen ja viel mehr über diesen Schwarzmarkt ganz normal. Hm.
Generell. Ja, der ähnlich entdeck.
Uhr.
Das wussten wir sowas im Leistungskatalog Katalog von Gamma schon vorher. Also, dass sie diese Dinger, die ins Regal gestellt, ne, ins Rect mit reingestellt werden und Softwareupdates kaputt machen, äh, zerstören oder so, äh, da bereithalten, ne?
Der ganze Spagat zwischen Krieg, die Sicherheit zu welchen Markt für die Mieter eigentlich.
Also ich finde die sind äh Bereiche, die sie sich jetzt nicht.
Was ja nichts ändert. Ich meine nur, weil man, weil man viele in ein Gesetz schreibt, kann es ja nicht sein, man schreibt da jetzt so viel rein, äh dass man den ein oder anderen Quatsch ähm durchkriegt.
Mhm.
Was was bedeutet denn das jetzt eigentlich konkret für den schon erwähnten neuen Trojaner, der jetzt ja so toll äh und gesetzeskonform daherkommt.
Technisch bei Skype geht das ja,
Also da das so haben ja schon immer diese Trojaner Skype Module und auch irgendwie Skype Call Recorder und solche Sachen funktioniert und wenn ich mich nicht täusche war das doch bei dem Digitals Trojaner auch so
dass du quasi ein ein Skype-Flug-in wirst, was äh in dem Moment, wo ein Telefonat anfängt,
ich glaube als Audiodevice oder sowas,
das ganze Ding nochmal auf eine Datei wegschreibt, ne? Das heißt also,
kriegt man bei Skype dieser dieser einen Anforderung,
nur Kommunikation aufzeichnen, der wird man im Falle von Skype vermutlich gerecht.
Wäre jetzt so meine Zukunft. Einer ist, du wirst ja also der Film drei Monate. Mhm. Also.
Mhm.
Ich hab diese eine technische Anforderung, dass der die Nachladen ist, dann,
Nachladen ist ist natürlich so ein Problem, du kannst den Trojaner äh nicht guten Gewissens ohne Nachladefunktion bauen.
Wenn der es könnte ja auch sein, dass du,
versehentlich einen schlech äh kaputten, ein nicht funktionsfähigen,
nicht gesetzmäßigen oder sonst was da hochlädst, du brauchst diese Funktion zum Update, allein schon wie du gerade sagst, Skype Update, Betriebssystem, Update oder sowas, du willst
nachladen können. Ähm.
Genau und du musst ihn ja auch entfernen können, das heißt in äh in dem Moment du du nimmst einen Eingriff in die Intimität vor, indem du ihn dahin bringst und du musst dann irgendwie auch dafür sorgen, dass der, dass er entfernt wird. Ähm.
Im Sinne von, wenn sie funktionsunfähig oder sowas, also natürlich wird sie nicht limitiert werden.
Genau und in dem das ist, denke ich, wahrscheinlich das, wo die sich am meisten Sorgen machen,
wenn der jetzt irgendwen, wenn der detektiert wird und auf einmal die Signaturen in irgendwelchen Virenscannern sind,
Dann willst du auf den Knopf drücken und deinen nächsten äh Deploin, ne? Also einfach,
dass der nicht mehr detektiert wird. Also so macht man das halt.
Ja.
Sowas ist da nicht geregelt. Ich meine, das wäre äh haben sie da nicht auch warum äh verlangen sie da eine Regelung zu oder sagen sie da.
Online-Durchsuchung.
Nein.
Da sind wir auch wieder bei bei dem Punkt, den ich gerade ansprechen wollte. Sie haben diese Kontrolle. Ja, was wird jetzt was,
So, Trojaner hat gesammelt, äh hat nach Hause gefunkt, jetzt gibt's da einen Haufen,
Gesprächsprotokoll vielleicht sogar Dateien, wenn's Unterdurchsuchung ist und dann wurde vorgeschrieben, es
unabhängige Stelle sein, die dann dieses Material sichtet, ähm haben die da
Ideen, Vorschriften.
Welche Institutionen käme einem da in den Sinn? Andrea Vossov hat keine Zeit. Also sieht man in diese nie irgendwo die, also sie ist einfach sehr, sehr beschäftigt.
Also wer wäre das jetzt die politische Institution.
Stück davon haben wir eigentlich gen.
Dann natürlich hoffentlich so groß, dass man nicht einzelne davon äh,
identifiziert oder unter Druck setzen kann oder so, ne? Aber das hast halt.
Ja. Hoffen wir's.
Okay. Und.
Bei der, bei der TKÜ gilt dieser Anspruch nicht,
weil sie sagen, wir folgen der Argumentation, das ist eine Kommunikationsüberwachung, wenn ihr eine äh Kommunikationsüberwachung macht, dann müsst ihr euch auch sonst nicht äh.
Da gibt's keine unabhängige.
Ähm entstehen dadurch auch äh Fragen für die Beschlagnahme von Speichermedien.
Die äh Absätze zweihundertsiebenundzwanzig und,
folgende, glaube ich. Ja, ich hab's online gesehen, du hast glaube ich keine Abseitsnummerierung in der ausgedruckten Welt. Ach, doch hast du. Ja, ja, genau, also der zwei siebenundzwanzig oder zwei siebzehn oder sowas war das?
Online machen könnte. Ich hab's eigentlich nur mit der.
Um anzugeben, wie viel Papier das ist, doppelseitig bedruckt, beidseitig bedruckt, äh ein guter Zentimeter.
Ja, es ist äh also wobei das jetzt so.
Ja. Sie sind ja auch.
Und die Quellen TKÜ auch und das sogar zu, sagen wir mal sehr viel lascheren Voraussetzungen, als wir die also.
Die Argumentation oder ich frage jetzt mal deine Argumentation wäre eigentlich schon gewesen, dass im Prinzip die Trennung oder das wäre echt meine Argumentation wäre. Eine Trennung zwischen äh Quellen TKÜ und ähm,
Online-Durchsuchung ähm ist eigentlich nicht haltbar. Nicht technisch verargumentier und haltbar.
Ja
Du hast den Schwarzwald aus dazu, aber die Infotation mal.
Das heißt, du lötest eine, du lötest eine Wanze in ein Telefon, ähm dann kannst du mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit sagen, dass diese Wanze,
Eine Funktion hat, sie ist ein Mikrofon und ähm diese Funktionalität kann man irgendwie,
gewährleisten, aber das ist eben der Unterschied zwischen einer Hardware und einer Software
Ähm, dass die Software eben grundsätzlich vor allem, wenn sie schon Kommunikation abhören kann,
einfach auf dem System mit einem mit einer Berechtigung läuft, die es ihr im Prinzip auch alles andere ermöglicht, weil,
Computer als allerletztes zu unterscheiden weiß was eine Funktion ist, die jetzt gerade ausführen soll oder nicht
die im Interesse seines Nutzers ist oder nicht und ob eine, ob ein Datum, eine Kommunikation, ein Bild, eine Datei, wenn nun Kernbereich ist oder nicht.
Ja. Ja und das ist halt letztlich.
Das beste Beispiel ist, du machst ein Gesetz zur Kommunikations äh zur Telekommunikationsüberwachung und ein paar Jahrzehnte später äh schreiben die Leute auf einmal Software und sagen, hey Qualität, ne? Also das ist ja genau so ein ein schönes Beispiel dafür, dass was für Folgen so ein Gesetz haben kann,
in Jahren oder Jahrzehnten, wenn es im neuen Licht interpretiert wird.
Verschiedenen Gründen auch aus technisch, aber nicht nur. Also ich glaube auch so ein bisschen.
Könnte auch teuer werden für die Behörden und irgendwann lassen sich's sein. Ich lese gerade, dass äh koalpotiert wird, dass das FBI für diesen,
einmaligen Zugriff auf das äh,
sagte iPhone die eins Komma drei vier Millionen US Dollar abgedrückt hat.
Bühne im Jahr.
Für ihren, für ihren Staatsregiona.
Teuer werden.
Tja, aber beim Geld wird's ja dann meistens sehr konkret, was politische Entscheidungen betrifft so.
Ich dachte sie haben doch.
Schaukuck. Das sind die hunderttausend Euro, die an Garmer gegangen sind oder was.
Ja
Ja oder der Test war beendet, dadurch, dass sie mit denen ins Geschäft gekommen sind, ne? Das äh.
Bei welchen denn das? Also Gama. Weiß man ja das also. Ja.
Warum? Also wissen natürlich auch nicht, welche Version.
Wer ist noch auf dem Markt Hacking Team? Ähm.
Ich bin auf weit weg, weil ich weiß, wie sehr du das magst.
Zwischendurch. Zwisch.
Was soll ich denn? Wo soll ich was recherchieren? Ich bin ganz für euch da.
Liste der Produzenten von Staatstrojanern.
Ich widme mich, würde ja dann nochmal interessieren, gab's irgendetwas dazu? Also,
viele der Trojaner äh Azure Service Leistung,
die haben ja sowas wie, dass sie, dass der Command Control-Server eben auch,
von von der Firma, die den Trojaner bereitstellt,
unterhalten wird. Das heißt du ja,
gehacking asse Service, ne? Das heißt, die haben auch die, die Infrastruktur, die updaten denen und du hast halt ein Backend für den Zugriff. Gab's da irgendwelche ähm gab's da Urteile zu? Oder gab's da äh Meinungen zu? Weil man geht ja so davon aus, dass ähm der Staat hackt jetzt äh seine
Feinde oder seine Gegner. Ähm.
Sehr häufig sieht man ja dann eben etwas andere Infrastrukturen, wo eben äh mehr oder weniger eine Firma,
beauftragt wird eine ein Ziel zu hacken und die es ein,
einen einzelnen oder einige wenige Command Control-Server gibt, wo diese Trojaner dann hin berichten,
die Kunden in dem Fall die Strafverfolgungsbehörden oder die anderen Kriminellen, die sich bei denen Dienstleistungen einkaufen, äh loggen sich dann da ein. Gibt's da zufällig in dem Urteil irgendeine,
'ne Maßgabe zu, dass sowas nicht passieren darf.
Oder das Speichern der Dateien auf äh auch nur interem Speichern, auf Infrastruktur, die nicht äh keine Debatten zeigen.
Mhm.
Das ist dürfte ich, ja?
Und irgendwie was was man da nimmt, da schreibt man dann hin äh Staatsrainer Staats. Was haben wir hier benutzt? Quälticatrojaner oder so, ne? Da würde man sich ja schon irgendwie wünschen, dass die wenigsten
wenigstens dokumentieren, welches Bein sich zu welchem Zeitpunkt da befunden hat,
sei es nur mit einer eigenen Hashfunktion, also also dass man wenigstens.
Im Zweifelsfall nachweisen kann, was man da hatte, ne? Also das ist ja dann in,
Gut, die können sich natürlich auch gleichzeitig denken, wie schnell ihnen äh wenn sie da irgendeine Lücke drin haben, wie schnell irgendein Anwalt ihn sie da auf äh Rausgabe verklagt.
Teuer, teuer wird für sie ja ohnehin nur der Quellenteppicher Trojaner. Für alles andere, wenn du keine ähm
technischen Vorgaben über die Limitation deines Einsatzmittelhass, dann nimmst du ja lieber.
Trojaner von der Stange, äh irgendwie wie,
jemand im Bundestag gemacht hat, denn die haben ja keinen Staatstrojaner dahin geschickt, sondern die haben halt,
mit Mimicats einfach sich eingebaut, ja? Also das äh damit du eben im Falle der,
ne? Also
du hast ja, wenn du jetzt auf deinem Computer eine Trojanerinfektion feststellst oder eine Unregelmäßigkeit und du stellst fest, dass diese Unregelmäßigkeit äh Skype betrifft, dann kannst du dir ungefähr denken, äh wo lang der Hase läuft, wenn du ähm,
Eine allgemeine trojane Infektion feststellt, dann bleibt für dich immer alles offen zwischen, du bist Teil eines riesigen Boardnetz äh oder was weiß ich,
Der Russe ist gekommen oder oder der Ami, ne? Also das heißt da darfst du ja Ermittlungsstrategisch äh.
Viel bessere Möglichkeiten,
mindestens im Falle der Entdeckung, erstens die Kosten gering zu halten, weil du dir einfach den nächsten Trojaner baust,
und zweitens im Falle der Entdeckung eben auch keinerlei Anhaltspunkte für zu
dass es sich um einen Staatsrealer handelt.
Mobiltelefone wird, also zehn Uhr ist, also.
Subgraf, jetzt müssen wir aber die Liste aufmachen.
Open BSC. Edu Bunto.
Siano Genmot, ha, du hast verloren. Okay.
Ja, wer sich will, wer richtig Plan hat, der kompliziert sich sein Betriebssystem eher sowieso selber und dann,
Gibt's da keine keinen? Nee. Aber das mag andere Gründe haben.
Hammers?
Das Fazit musst du äh machen. Also was mich vielleicht könntest du ja sagen, was hat sich hat sich jetzt für die wie ist jetzt die Prognose, wie also passieren wird, dem müssen wir BKA-Gesetz nachbessern.
Und das gilt für die ähm für die äh Infiltations äh Paragraphen.
Und in den, sage ich mal, den Bereichen, die wir interessant finden im Rahmen des Logbuch Netzboutique,
nee, nicht nicht.
Und die Beschränkung heißt im Prinzip das, was wir euch aufgegeben haben, äh das muss müsst ihr im Prinzip auch jetzt schon sicherstellen, wenn ihr nicht wollt, dass euch das Ding vor der Nase. Ja.
Es heißt ein Kampf, der weiß nicht jetzt äh neun zehn Jahre gedauert hat gegen,
Die Trojanisierung,
gegen Angriffe auf die Integrität und Vertraulichkeit unserer Informationstechnischen Systeme,
geht mit diesem Urteil,
Nun zu Ende hatte seinen Höhepunkt zweitausendacht,
ein Grundrecht und hat jetzt sein
vorläufiges Ende gefunden mit starken,
Auflagen, die für die Online-Durchsuchung. Und nicht besonders hohen für die Quellen TKÜ.
Da ist natürlich die bei der Online äh bei der Quellen TKÜ haben wir natürlich, wie gesagt, den den Vorteil als Zivilbevölkerung,
dass wir ja alle Backups von unseren Systemplatten machen und lange aufbewahren und damit dann in diesen Backups forensische Analysen im Rahmen der allgemeinen,
Sorgfaltspflicht durchführen.
Denke, wir würden sicherlich,
wenn ihr dann irgendwann mal begründeten Anlass habt
dass ihr äh gesegnet wurdet von der Quellen-TKÜ,
noch Backups habt von den Systemen, dann haben wir sehr viele technisch interessierte Mitglieder in unserem Verein, die sich solche Sachen natürlich sehr gerne anschauen,
Ich gebe dir aber trotzdem jetzt noch kurz den Nachschub bei begründetem Anlass. Ja, weil,
Also nichts gegen die äh besorgten ähm äh Computersportler, ähm die äh sich,
vorbildlich, um die Integrität äh und Vertraulichkeit ihrer Informationstechnischen Systeme sorgen. Aber es sollte dann schon irgendwie so halbwegs anders bezogen sein. Eine Analyse sollte,
erforderlich sein. Und notwendig.
Und sie muss zum Ende kommen.
Vielen herzlichen Dank für deinen unermüdlichen Einsatz über Jahre in diesem Bereich. Ich hoffe, du bist jetzt.
Ich in diesem ein.
Jetzt in Rente.
Nein, in diesem Teilbereich deines äh deines Schaffens, in diesem Teilbereich, deines Schaffens. Wir müssen uns um diese Fluggastdaten äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung kümmern.
Na, siehst du mal, die digitalen Sabatisten, die haben immer was zu tun, da Lutschers, Siggis, Siggi.
Wer hätte gedacht, dass Gerhard Waum nochmal hier der Führer der Resistance werden würde.
Ja vom äh ja schwerter zum Flugschaden und Innenminister zu Freiheitskämpfern.
Weit ist es gekommen.
Weit ist es gekommen. Könnte schlechter laufen. Also wir haben schon bisschen positiv. War doch positiv.
Also du meinst die Leute beim BKH. Ich will dich doch nur ärgern, nein.
Das sieht nicht ins Boxhorn jagen. Alles super,
vielen Dank und.
Das musstest du am Ende nochmal sagen, ja, das ist gut.
Das ist also das kann man nicht wecken lacken. Ja super. Das äh hören wir natürlich sehr gerne.
Wir sind ja auch totaler Fan, was? Ja, wir müssen aufhören. Tschau, tschau, tschüss jetzt hier Feierabend. Danke.